[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
so how are you guys doing so last week i
had a transgender individual
as a guest for the 10th episode of the
mh podcast
and there was a lot of coverage in terms
of the issues that were raised
we spoke about different things from
biology all the way through to religion
but one thing that came up
which i don't think got the treatment
that it deserved in terms of
speaking about it was the um the idea of
trans regret
because when i went away and did my
research and looked at some of the
youtube
you know videos that were made by
individuals who regretted the decisions
that they had made
i came across so many different videos
one in particular caught my eye
of a 13 year old boy who had regretted
started to take
estrogen blockers and so on or you know
testosterone blockers
and estrogen or some kind of medication
and then later on regretted it and in
fact wanted a surgery
to remove their breasts
which they had gotten from this
medication let's take a look at a clip
from that video
you've grown breasts haven't you as a
result of the hormone therapy that you
were being given
yeah so i just started developing like a
girl would
and which was the thing that i wanted at
that time but now that's not so helpful
she's taking drastic action to have her
young son's breasts
surgically reduced ally wants to warn
other parents what can go wrong when
doctors
misdiagnose a child as transgender
they were wrong to pigeonhole him so
quickly
i think they should have said here we
have a child who
does have gender dysphoria and he's
going through a period of transition
where he needs to work out exactly how
he feels
so what we can see here is a classic
case of an individual who is encouraged
by society
to go in a direction which could have if
he continued with that direction had
such a life-altering
effect on them that they would have been
scarred for life quite
physically imagine going all the way
through with our srs surgery
to the extent whereby you remove your
genitalia as a as a male
your your penis and your testicles and
you cannot retrieve them back
they will be put into some kind of bag
and they're thrown away
now you just imagine that for a second
these kinds of
psychological states of minds dysphorias
that individuals have gender dysphorias
that can lead someone to that and then
regret that thereafter
because of an ethic that we have in the
west that says it's okay to identify
with whatever you feel like you want to
identify with
it's something i believe which does need
to be challenged head-on
but it needs to be challenged head-on
not only within our community
the muslim community but outside of it
in a diplomatic and respectful
and academic way i don't think the way
to deal with
you know these kinds of individuals who
have these kinds of dysphorias and
psychological
conditions should be shunned
i don't believe that they should be
thrown away i don't believe that the
discussion should be
no discussion and unfortunately although
the majority of muslims
on social media were very positive
there was a very loud minority who i
must say
was were bringing forward a toxic kind
of attitude which i don't think is
conducive for anybody
not for the muslim community not for the
non-muslim community not for the daoa
not for the spreading of islam not for
anything
and we have to learn a new level of
maturity now when dealing with these
issues
i've been dealing with these issues for
half a decade not that long not that
long but enough to know
that there's a way of doing it which is
effective in a way which is not
effective
we've seen christian missionaries and
apologists in the bible bell america use
the you know sledgehammer approach
and it's been the biggest failure of all
things
homosexuality is an abomination swearing
you know shunning and all this and then
you know at the end of it people are
isolated alienated and it doesn't work
muslims some muslims have attempted to
adopt similar methods
we're getting similar results quite
frankly right so what i think needs to
be done
is that we need to change our attitude
we need to remember when lorta
salaam when he was having conversations
with homosexuals
yes he did tell them not to do certain
things and yes he did
condemn the actions but he also offered
his daughters in marriage
now i want you to think about one thing
how can you offer your daughters in
marriage
uh disrespectfully think about that as a
question right
if you offered his daughters in marriage
given them an option to heterosexuality
yeah to this these group of people said
look you know just
we'll make it work and giving them an
option to do
the the good actions how can you do that
whilst at the same time being
disrespectful to them
and being inhospitable to them it's not
possible that that can be the case
so law ta'ala islam therefore if we
ponder over these verses with care
will realize is employing different
kinds of approaches
but is engaging with them speaking with
them and being respectful with them
this minority of muslim people who are
on social media
not even happy with the fact that these
discussions are taking place quite
frankly you are part of the problem
and you are the you are the kind of
people who
will bring us back as a community we
will not be able to
to help members of our community with
these issues
nor people outside of our communities
with these issues
so what needs to happen is people just
need to go back into their lanes
people need to realize that they may not
be
qualified yeah or experienced enough to
talk about every issue
and being you might find a transgender
person disgusting
you might find that but let me tell you
something there are people on the other
side
who find you disgusting right they look
at your beard and they look at you or
maybe
a woman within the club and they find
that disgusting and they will never
engage with those people because
those people to them are the alien
therefore they will never be able to
influence those people
we're saying look it's not about your
aesthetic value judgments you might find
people discussing but you still have to
engage with them
and respect them and give them the truth
this is
our and this is what we need to do
finally i want to to say to you guys
that this should be a learning curve for
everybody not everybody needs to comment
about everything
and when you're talking on behalf of
islam or as a muslim
realize that you can make one comment
one comment
to members of a particular community
that would have otherwise been neutral
to islam and muslims that will destroy
that will destroy the image of islam and
muslim for that individuals for life
and that's why such a beautiful quote in
the quran allah subhanahu ta'ala says
be patient with what they say and leave
them
a beautiful living meaning leave them as
neutrals
don't leave people that could otherwise
be receptive to the islamic message
yeah hating islam because of the way you
spoke to them
or the way you've dealt with them which
is a completely un-islamic way
i think we have to acknowledge there are
a lot of children who are confused about
their gender
identity as as a normal phase that they
would go through
it's not uncommon to be confused the
good news
is they're going to grow out of it don't
mess them up
you